на велику мету вони пляшка і маша були
дні волосся тепер нечасто часті на
амстердама та з дпс кроку ведмедика
бідніть обидва порубати не люди жити а тут
видозмінюється і вид овочі про можна
сміття відкинь амстердама
[музика]
ніхто не знаєте волосся краще за павуля
сфер діра
even соціальний противник і в жопу на 40
руки vdo допомагаючи людям силу району як
соціальних проблем під завжди був дуже
мало через економічний спад інших
руки
стало ще більше навколо фейл за тегами
дуже багато боргів ivan the machine
істоти тішили бариги на першій місії
обсі а ганс гейнц кармаліта doors одна
з тих то понісши в спиртному зупинки
з фербер домагається їжа пункти
doors емігрантка суринам у вона купила ми
були ура рядок червоними прочитала розуму ви
і біля води ще були написані грибним
шрифтом сокира щура закони заходу до дати
а чий
жалю про покупку троє людей може
дивитись тут і двоє тут осі все вона
купила c лише q10 руки в тумані язиком я
хотіла платити євро рядок алани
побачила чого вона була 514 адже сотки
всі ці рук і оплатила заварки кмітливий
Алли було ні в морі покривати ще й вигляд
сотка
як результат тина 2 затятого лише до
зближалася з 1800 євро до тисяч
doors на знає з чоловіка хоч cool з-під
це чу суму
нині фінансовий стан матері-одиначки
моніторити закон опікуна side of
incoming цієї на шкіру опіату руди на у
нідерландах прибирання
собою худобу 20 вид сотки з ще включилась
osinka
купила зайву в середньому шкірно руди наук
тяжа на багами ви на 40 тисяч євро
філдінг free офіцер зендора адже чай
так їх родем стрибати для радості партій
та кіберу
доля у виборщик полігонах правий
популізм герт вілдерс
шановні мігранти вона економічніша
важко ще й причину та соціальних
проблем україни люди розруху ще кулі
так і так допоможе ви вирішите їхню некрозу
ізобар вова ністю
на прокладку хвалять жорсткі закони для
захоплення споживача
вона лиж і гарного war ця каламут процес
нині місця запас плечі нагодували ту
газову плиту
у того і треба видати і знову залазить і в
барбі
двадцятому їй старі плати зламалася а
сир і ми не доводилося чекати і без
нормальні плити копор'я взяти на місце
амстердам
чим до щаслива бачати світла в кінці
тунелю а джек і найбагатшим голландцям і
лише з первинного очищення на
амстердама і доводьте пащ нас води
таким систем team та
[музика]